I'm about to show you how the AI
benchmarks game is rigged and why the
biggest players have every incentive to
keep it that way. I'm Darius, CEO of
Scorecard. I built evaluation systems at
Whimo and Uber ATG for salt driving
cars, which are really the OG AI agents
and for rockets at SpaceX. I also have
patents from Whimo on how to evaluate
autonomous systems. Now, my team and I
work with leaders in AI across legal
tech, health tech, and finance, and
we've seen every eval trick in the book.
Here's what we'll cover. First, why
benchmarks control billions in market
value and mind share. Second, the three
most common ways companies gain the
system. And third, how to build
evaluations that actually
work. First off, what is a benchmark? It
a benchmark is composed of three
components. A model you're testing, a
set of questions we call the test set,
and a metric, how we keep the score. But
here's what's important to understand. A
benchmark is actually composed of many
individual eval bundled together. And
the key insight is that benchmarks
standardize the test set and metrics
across these models. And that's what
makes them
comparable. Think of it like the SAT.
The same questions, same scoring system,
just different test
takers. But here's the things. These
scores control billions of market value
investment decisions and public
perception.
Simon Willis said it best. Billions of
dollars of investment are now being
evaluated based on these
scores. When OpenAI or Enthropic claims
the top spot, it's not just about
funding. It's about enterprise
contracts, developer mind share, and
market dominance. When Andre Karpathy
tweets about your benchmark has millions
of followers, that shapes entire
ecosystems.
Recently, Sona acquired Auto
Rover. Why? Auto Rover showed strong
results on SWE. So, we have a system
where a single number can define market
leaders and destroy competitors. What
could possibly go
wrong? Well, when the stakes are this
high, people find creative ways to win.
Let me show you the most common
tricks. The first trick is simple. You
make apples to orange comparisons.
Here's a recent example. XAI released
benchmark results for Gro 3. Beautiful
graphs showing them beating everyone.
The AI community went wild. But then
open engineers started looking closer.
They noticed something interesting. XI
was comparing their best configuration
against other modules standard
configurations. It's like comparing your
sports car with nitrous booster against
regular cars without it. Specifically,
they didn't show OpenAI 03's models high
performance at consensus 64. That's when
you run the model 64 times and take
consensus answer. Now, consensus at 64
is much more expensive. You're literally
running the model 64 times. But if
you're claiming performance leadership,
you need to compare the best to the best
or standard standard, not the best
against their
standard. And this selective reporting
is just the tip of the iceberg.
The second trick is more controversial.
Getting privileged access to test
questions. Frontier Math was supposed to
be this super secret impossible to gain
benchmark for advanced mathematics. The
creators made a big deal about how um
it's really protected. But here's what
actually happened. OpenAI funded
Frontier Math and got access to the
entire data set. Now to be fair, there's
a verbal agreement that they won't train
on the data and OpenAI employees have
publicly called it a strongly held out
evaluation set. But you have to think
about the optics here. The company
funding the benchmark is to see all the
questions, evaluate their models
internally, and announce their scores
before there's independent verification.
When OpenAI announced that 03 had scored
um a surprisingly strong 25%, people
were surprised. Uh even if everything is
above board, and it might be, this
creates a trust problem. When benchmark
creators take money from the companies
they're evaluating, it undermines the
whole
system. But even this isn't the most
subtle trit. That honor goes to trick
number
three. This one's really fascinating. So
models can optimize for style over
substance. Here's a real example. Meta
released Llama 4 Maverick to the public,
but behind the scenes they entered 27
different versions into LM arena. Each
one tweaked to maximize appeal, not
necessarily accuracy. One of the private
versions was asked to make a riddle with
the answer 3.145.
It gave a long, emoji-filled, flattering
response that made absolutely no sense,
but it beat Claude's correct answer. Uh,
why? Because it was chatty and engaging,
not because it was right. This is
happening right now. Companies are
literally training models to be wrong,
but charming. Researchers at LM Marina
proved we can control for this. When
they filtered out style effects, length,
formatting, personality, the rankings
completely changed. GBD40 Mini and and
Grock 2 dropped out and Claude 3.5
Sonnet jumped up and and tied for first.
We're really not measuring which model
is most accurate. We're measuring which
model is most charming. It's like
choosing a surgeon based on bedside
manner instead of surgical skill. Even
human SATs have this problem. 39% of
score variance in SAT scores is just
essay length. If you write more, you
score higher.
We have the technology measure what
matters but the industry prefers
measuring what sells. And this brings us
to the fundamental
problem. All of this is an natural
outcome of good arts good hearts law.
When a measure becomes a target, it
ceases to be a good
measure. We've turned benchmarks into
targets worth billions. So of course
they've stopped measuring what actually
matters. The incentives guarantee it.
Speaking of
which, this isn't just my opinion.
Listen to what the experts, the people
who create these benchmarks are saying.
Andre Krothy, co-founder of OpenAI. My
reaction is that there is an evaluation
crisis. I don't really know what metrics
to look at right now. Let that sink in.
The co-founder of OpenAI doesn't know
which metrics to trust. John Yang, who
created Sweetbench. It's sort of like we
kind of just made these benchmarks up.
Martin Sat from CMU. The yard sticks are
like pretty fundamentally
broken. Um, and many more. When the
people who build the benchmark say
they're broken, when the leaders of AI
say they don't trust the metrics, we
have a serious
problem. So, how do we fix
this? To fix public metrics, we need to
address all three components. the model
comparisons, the test sets, and the
metrics. For model comparisons, we need
to require apple comparisons. You need
to have the same computational budget,
same constraint, no cherry-picking of
configurations. You also need to show
cost performance trans uh trade-offs
transparently. So on the right here, we
see uh the arc prize where they've done
just that. For test sets, we also need
transparency. We need to open source the
data and have methodologies and clo code
with no financial ties between the
benchmark creators and the model
companies. In addition, we need to have
regular rotation of the test questions
to prevent
overfitting. Finally, for metrics, we
need to be able to control for style
effects so that we can measure
substance, not just engagement. And we
also need all attempts to be uh required
public so that there's no possibility of
cherrypicking your best
run. The good news is we're seeing
progress. LM Marina style uh controlled
rankings gives us some um ability to
remove styles as a component and we're
also seeing the emergence of more and
more independent benchmarks in specific
domains. These open source efforts to
create uh benchmarks include legal
bench, medqa and fintech as well as the
crosscut coding efforts of agent eval
and better bench to actually benchmark
benchmarks. But if you really want to v
win the evaluation game, there's a
better
way. You can't win a rigged game, so you
stop playing it.
Instead of chasing public benchmarks,
you should build a set of evaluations
that actually matter for your use case.
And here's
how. Step one, you gather real data.
Taking five actual queries from your
production system is
worth way way more than 100 academic
questions. These real user problems beat
synthetic benchmarks every time.
Step two, choose your metrics. Quality,
cost, latency. Pick what matters for
your application. A chatbot needs
different metrics in a medical diagnosis
system. Step three, test the right
models. Don't just go by the
leaderboards. Test the top five models
on your specific data. GPT4 might top
generic benchmarks, but fail on your
legal
documents. Step four, you systematize
it. You need consistent, repeatable
evaluation. Build it yourself or use a
platform like Scorecard. Step five, keep
iterating. Models improve, your needs
change. Make evaluation a continuous
process, not a onetime
event. At Scorecard, this is how we do
it. We've built a complete workflow. You
identify issues. You build improvements.
Then you run evaluations before
deployment. It's a continuous cycle. You
run evals, you get feedback, you
improve, and then you only deploy when
you hit your quality bar, then you
monitor and start again. This
pre-eployment evaluation loop is what
separates teams that that ship reliable
AI from teams that are constantly
firefighting production
issues. Yes, this takes more work than
just checking a leaderboard, but it's
the only way to build AI that actually
serves your
users. And here's the bottom line. The
benchmarks game is rigged because
there's too much at stake for it not to
be. Market caps, acquisitions, developer
mind share. It all hinges on these
numbers. But you don't have to play
their game. You can build evaluations
that actually help you ship better
products. Measure what matters to your
users, not what matters to
Twitter. All benchmarks are wrong, but
some are useful. The key is knowing
which
ones. Thanks for watching. Now go build
evals that mean something.